j'ai aimé
J'ai adoré l'Amérique
america l'auteur de cette
chanson c'est Michel Sardou que
voil amé
[Des rires]
améri amérique
amérique ce petit vous avez Vu ce petit
Je l'ai connu tu en culotte courte comme
et venez voir son papa qui chantait dans
les coulisses regardez comment IL a
grandi IL est Grand ce petit tu m'as
fait départ Au moment o sa pas
attention
petit fais plaisir fou
Marcel fais plaisir ton
paternel et chante nous
tournée
petit devant les
[Musique]
on a toujours très peur d'oublier ces
chansons Je voulais Me cacher juste
avant l'émission
tellement
maintenant, je te fais chier
voici Ne nous raconte pas ta
ven
vas-y c'est un dimanche après
midi les gens sont heureux et
gentils ils sont Vénus pour
s'amuser IL s'IL vois que Je cherche
Mon texte je crois que tu peux commencer
Je vais alors petite attention ton p
regarde tout le monde te regarde fais
attention